was a Muslim Moses was a Muslim Jesus
likewise Abraham likewise what do what
do I do do I mean by that doesn't not
mean they speak in Arabic language no
what it means they submit themselves to
God according to God's teaching so
that's the Islamic teaching now in order
for you to to worship God correctly you
have to follow Prophet Muhammad because
look to what's name
if you look to Prophet Muhammad if you
look to Christianity the Bible Jesus
what language he
spoke
huh Aramaic Aramaic or syri they
different the stor is different about it
but the point here is we not even sure
what language he spoke okay but we not
sure facts he didn't speak Greek that we
have the Bible I mean the Bible we have
in Greek and even that we have different
languages as well but how can we trans
translate if we don't know them so I'm
going to worship God based upon a book
firstly I don't know who wrote it
because the earliest manuscript that you
we have for the Bible because you know
the Bible that we have for example King
James ESV NIV or others other Bibles is
based upon the manuscripts you with
me yeah of course because why
translation good yeah so it's not about
even interpretation is different thing
okay but the point here is the text we
don't have the text even the Christian
Scholars not all of them but a lot of
them they say we don't know we cannot
really uh Trace back what really Jesus
said just assume but when it comes to
Quran we have the miracle of the Quran
we still have it in it pure
language also it's been memorized by 100
million of Muslims word for word letter
for letter you see and for example not
of the Jewish and the Christians and the
what they call it the the the the the
the Muslims decides to burn the
scripture the scriptures the only
scripture remain with us is the Quran
the Quran it has been memorized by
people don't even speak the language and
not Allah mentioned that in the Quran
because Allah mentioned that 1,400 years
ago that Allah in the verse in
Arabic we have made Quran easy to be
memorized that is a claim can we verify
this claim yes we can you go to Africa
you go to come to Europe go to Asia go
to other countries around the world or
other continents you meet Muslims at the
age of 9 and 10 the Quran word forward
later for later so how a man that
existed 1,400 years ago was able to tell
us something which we can verify right
now likewise Allah said in the
Quran we have sent down the the
Revelation in the Quran and we will
preserve it and yes the Quan be
preserved work for it like for example
all of us here will memorize the
alphabet I mean I can change it by
writing a o c but everyone's going to
correct me said no it's a b c d e you
know because you memorize it so the
Quran it has been memorized likewise
there many miracles of the Quran for
example the prophecies in the Quran you
know one of the prophets in the Quran
that Allah told us in the
Quran uh Islam will spread out even if
this Believers Tred to stop it now we
know the fast growing religion on the
face of the earth is Islam
even there's a huge War by social media
not social media mainstream media try to
make Islam look bad but people are still
accepting Islam because Islam goes in
line with our natural inclination with
our sound reasoning you understand that
there's only one God who is that God
Allah describe
himself say Allah is one is unique Allah
is a master self-sufficient everything
is in need of him but he not he's not in
need of
nothing he be not neither was he
begotten there's nothing like unto God
that's the Creator believe in when it
come to Christianity Jesus Is God or
when it comes to Judaism is a tribal God
or when it comes to Buddhism Buddhism
again they even believe in God to be
honest it's a philosophy you understand
or Hinduism or Sikhism they believe in
the unitive existence which logically
doesn't make any sense how the universe
is God universe is created goes and
created that is the Paradox you know
what I'm saying that doesn't make any
sense that's why many people are very
attracts to Islam cuz like I said when
God create us he create us with the
tools within us that goes in line with
the Revelation that he will send down
it's like me making a p making a padlock
then of course if I make padlock I'm
going to make the key for it so if you
claim that you made it and you bring the
key you can't open it because you never
made it so the only key is going to open
the padlock is my key because I made it
likewise the only religion that goes in
line with our sound reasoning our
natural ination is Islam it makes sense
you understand so Jesus Is God doesn't
make any sense Jesus to be God Trinity
doesn't make any sense you know that's
not Jesus teaching Jesus came to teach
people about one God however the Roman
the pagans Chang everything so when you
look to Islamic teaching which is based
upon the two most important thing
testify there's no one worthy of worship
except Allah and Muhammad the messenger
of Allah what you think said make sense
so the B said why don't you become
Muslim then why is stop to become Muslim
if it makes sense h Huh you want to
become
Muslim alhamdulillah and you can can do
it here is's my our witness here aldah
you can do as well alhamdulillah because
not Islam you know how how old are you
18 my wife become Muslim when she was 14
my wife is a reverse my wife is solution
okay she's mixed well like you this
mixed business you know
say
again where by
who no we I don't know by the not by the
Muslims no because as a Muslim you have
to love them you have to take care of
them the reverts for example you as
becoming a Muslim you got double reward
as a Christian and becoming a Muslim
because now you believe in Jesus the way
Jesus wants to believe in him you
understand so RS are very respected and
of course I'm not tell you every Muslim
is a good man or every Muslim woman is a
good woman there's good and bad evil but
Islam is perfect Muslims are not perfect
but Islam is perfect so we come in a
Muslim is a two testimony which is I
bear witness there's nothing worthy of
worship except Allah and I bear witness
Muhammad the messenger of Allah that's
step by step because something you have
to understand all of us including myself
any time we can live this life and we're
going to die how many people left the
house they never come back how many
people won't sleep they never wake up
there's many people like your age and my
age have passed away and you know that's
why our Prophet Muhammad
am uh Tau us to visit the graveyard why
the graveyard summarized the reality of
this life the life that we we are
tracing the life that we are fighting
our brothers and our sisters for one day
we're going to leave it and in the grave
God is not going to ask you what is your
background or it's about your belief and
your
actions as Allah said except those who
Bel correct belief the believe that God
wants to believe in no not the Greek
Romans or other nations no God that's
why the Islamic teaching is been
preserved then I can tell you what to
say in English which is I bear witness
there's nothing worthy of worship except
Allah and I be witness Muhammad the
messenger of Allah that's how you become
Muslim then of course step by step you
starting how to pray how to give zakat
all this takes time okay and the example
I always give imagine you have a big
cake front of you big cake if you eat
all of it at once what will happen to
you he sick in order for you to feel the
sweetness of the cake what you
do bit by bit likewise when it comes to
Islam step by step the most important
thing which Jesus came with Moses came
with Abraham came with and the last of
the Prophet Muhammad came with is the
Oneness of Allah to worship Allah alone
and to follow the teaching of that
Prophet if I was alive at the time of
Jesus in order for me to be saved I have
to follow Jesus teaching before Jesus
Moses now the last prophet is Muhammad
you know so if you want to become Muslim
alhamdulillah which I advise you to do
cuz it makes sense to you CU you even
know what will happen to you cuz you
don't want to die upon this belief the
biggest crime against God will he turn
away from his teaching you know example
I always give I'm not sure if the
brothers mentioned it to you imagine
both you in the
house tonight you you go to to your own
room and you go to sleep in the middle
of the night you wake up and there's a
fire in your own room everywhere both
you try your best to serve yourself and
you couldn't and I saved your life what
would you say to me if I do come and
save your life what would you say to me
thank you of course would you remember
me all the time of course you remember
me you remember shi shi always sh save
my life because I sa very de to you so
why we not grateful and remember who
give us a life for
free you understand now if you want to
buy a gift for your mother you want to
buy a gift the way what you love or your
mother Love Was Your Mother Love
likewise you want to worship you want to
be grateful to the Creator the way he
loves so this is the in summary the
analogy of the two testimony which is I
bear witness no one is worthy of worship
except Allah and I bear with mhammad the
messenger of Allah aldah ready I tell
you to say in English repeat after me
you become Muslim alhamdulillah then
step by
stepas I tell you say English I'm going
Arabic say after me I be
witness there's nothing wory of worship
in truth except Allah and I bear Witness
that Muhammad is the last's messenger
and the servant of Allah in
Arabic Allah I give you my brother I'm
very happy for you nice one man
alhamdulillah may Allah keep you firm
you know alhamdulillah I give you GL
Muhammad you
see alhamdulillah man you know and now
you be connect to your creator you know
and many people when they become Muslim
they feel emotional you know
alhamdulillah man I have Muslim here
your friend they can help you man
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah you have many now you are
part of a big Islamic Nation you know
like you see about R you R look how how
they he's a r he's a r they became
Muslims well you understand there's our
here well he's a revert he became Muslim
when 17 you know what I'm saying we have
another brother he's a Chinese he's a
revert you understand because like I
said to you Islam is a big nation it's
mixed so alhamdulillah but what I will
say to you Brothers learn you have to
learn okay because it's very important
to learn like you know learn what is
Allah's right over us because how many
people are walking past and they didn't
stop but Allah chose you stop you know
remember Allah is not in Allah is not in
need of us we are in need of Allah you
know and you want to worship the Creator
for example you have in the cross
islamically this cross is a paganism you
know when you go home take it off inah
but this this this by the way this has
nothing to do with Jesus well yeah cross
people as a fashion but you know because
remember anything is a pagan yes
alhamdulillah that's good man alhamd
taking off right now alhamdulillah man
yeah cuz this one is like you can put I
mean you can put another necklace silver
one but this one because is a sign of
paganism sign of disbelief alhamdulillah
but again take it easy step by step if
you need any questions you look around
here you around
here you my neighbors then not you my
neighbors alhamdulillah man we have a
most here yeah alhamdulillah you can
come to take our detail
inah they're from here bro yeah they
have m
we have
most bring them
in and they come Lear because we are
look you know this life is a
test
yeah yeah this life is a test Allah will
test Us in different ways but Allah
Allah said we will never make the
righteous equal to the evil ones and
what is righteousness is what God
legislated to be righteousness and the
most important thing
the most important thing worshiping God
alone like your families are not Muslims
all right so I advise you to do not be
nice to them okay be respectful to them